oh yes yes
oh I'm reading for the guy who left yeah
he's doing pretty well let's say okay
oh he's not good with nets I I'm okay
with nuts too I guess but oh he's doing
Bob Jesse going very well
oh go sir go please don't lose now
please don't lose now like Middle East's
do not know what he is doing
oh oh he was a fast one though he's good
Oh left one come on all right okay yeah
just a nice massage machine only like a
quarter so this is good
I notice your feet aren't getting
massaged innate but hmm don't you just
hate when that happens
oh my god okay let's see this guy if
he's doing this sounds good this guy's a
gun what it what has gone on here like
oh I say it's because he had his penis
out
you know many times I've been pulled
over for something like this so many
times like Jesus like that I have a
backpack full of tickets a backpack